the brainstorming session assumed that
there was in fact a market for a huge
market failure failure of regulatory
system and that you had this room
psychology that meant that people
thought you could leverage profit from
dead endless life that it was
sustainable but what became the real
issue who's going to share the blood is
going to stand up and say we were
responsible we apologize and take the
consequences in every other sector there
are rules of law are you working people
are the victims of a system that was
simply about casino capitalism and yet
here at Davos today as a labor leader on
continue we could nobody take the blame
it is absolutely horrendous that 15
million more unemployed people will be
the victims of a financial system that
got out of whack because people were
basically put don't read we need to make
sure that the resources are distributed
more equitably review that working
people not only have jobs but that
they're decent jobs the jobs where they
have rights collective bargaining rights
and that there is a framework of global
regulation not just national and local
regulation that says this could never
happen again so there's a little bit
more need for humility for honesty for
an acknowledgement that the financial
leaders the corporate leaders who played
into that financial environment got it
wrong